All right. So, here I am in cloud code
in the terminal right over here. What
you'll notice is that this agent is
actually my cloud code agent. So, when I
send off this message where I'm asking
it to spin up two researcher agents, one
to research Google, one to research
OpenAI and then create a visual diagram.
You'll see that this agent actually gets
that task. And now you can see that we
have three agents actually running right
now in parallel. This one's researching
Google AI strengths and this one is
researching OpenAI strengths. And this
is the main one that delegated the tasks
to those two researcher agents, which
you can also see on this right hand
side. That's exactly what's being ran
right now. And if I wanted to open up
another terminal, so I add another
agent, it plops in another agent right
here in which I can have a different
conversation with. Give me a quick
analysis of my YouTube comment section
from the past couple videos I've made.
So now I shoot that message off to this
AI agent in Claude Code, and it's going
to pick up the task and start working on
other things. As you can see now, this
one is searching files and finding out
what it needs to do. And you just heard
that little notification noise, which
means that this spun up a sub aent. And
you can see that it was analyzing
comments, but now it needs approval. So
basically, what we have here is a visual
way to see all of the different
terminals and sub aents that we have
working in cloud code. We get
notifications and we get visual things
like this that tell us what they're
doing. So I can see that those sub aents
on this lefth hand side are
disappearing. So, I can hop back over to
that first terminal and I'll be able to
see that this first one is already done.
And now the OpenAI one is still being
worked on, which is this agent right
over here. Okay. I don't know where
she's off to, but you can see now that
both of these agents are done. They're
idle. They're done working. So, in the
first terminal, we can see here's the
visual. It came out clean. We have stuff
about Google's edge, Google's gaps,
OpenAI's edge, OpenAI's gaps. So, here's
that actual visualization that it made.
We have strengths, weaknesses for both
Google and OpenAI. Sometimes AI
generation can be notoriously bad on
text, but this one looks pretty decent.
Only a few errors I can see. And then
coming over to the second terminal, we
can see the comment analysis over the
last two weeks. So we've got some pain
points about cloud API costs, ended into
cloud code, getting first client with
zero social proof, we've got most
requested videos, we've got notable
patterns, and then we have recent video
performance snapshot. But I'm sure you
guys could tell that the point of this
quick demo wasn't to actually show you
the outputs. It was to show you what we
were able to do here and how we could
see these two different terminal agents
spin up sub agents and we could keep
tabs on them visually. So,
unfortunately, I'm going to say goodbye
to these agents so we can get on with
the video and I'm going to kill these
terminal sessions right here so I can
actually explain to you guys how this
works and what I think about it. Okay,
so the way that we are doing this is we
are using Visual Studio Code and that's
where I've been using Cloud Code as an
extension. If you've been following my
channel for a while, we're using an
extension in VS Code called Pixel
Agents, which basically turns your AI
coding agents into animated pixel art
characters in a virtual office that you
can fully customize. So, I'll have a
link to this page right here, and I will
have a link to the GitHub repository in
the description, but I'll also show you
guys like exactly how you set this up.
So, before we actually jump into that,
real quick, just wanted to go over like
what are we doing here, and what is
Cloud Code? Because that's the little
agents that we were actually spinning
up. Well, Cloud Code is an AI in our
terminal. It can write and edit code. It
can understand our codebase and it can
run commands on our behalf. And what's
going on when you're using a coding
assistant like cloud code is you
basically are just looking at terminal
or you're looking at what the AI model
is thinking and what it's doing. But
what's actually happening behind the
scenes is files are getting read, plans
are being created, code is being
executed, and tests are being ran. So
there's a lot of stuff going on that we
don't really visually get to see,
especially when we start to spin up tons
of parallel agents and have different
terminals running. So basically what
happens is cloud code is working. It
creates an activity log that already
happened by default and pixel agents
basically just picks up that activity
log and then displays it in some sort of
animation. It's honestly a very similar
flow if you watch the way I set up my
OpenClaw personal assistant and I could
see what he was working on and if he
spun up any sub agents. And like I said,
it's pretty cool to be able to monitor
our different agents at a glance rather
than having to flip through different
terminals, especially because I love to
multitask when I'm using Cloud Code. So,
one monitor I'll be coding with stuff
and the other monitor I'll be working on
other things and I can just kind of
easily glance back and forth. So, if you
want to actually try this out for
yourself, it's super easy. You just have
to go download Visual Studio Code if you
don't have it already. Unfortunately,
right now there's only support for
Windows. So, if you're on a Mac or a
different operating system, I don't
think you can use this yet. This
literally came out like a few days ago.
But anyways, once you are in a fresh
instance of VS Code, this is what it
will look like. And what you'll do is on
this left-hand side, you'll come over to
extensions and you'll literally just
type in pixel agents. And if you type in
pixel agents, you'll be able to see
right here pixel art office where your
cloud code agents come to life. This is
the one that I installed and have just
showed you as a demo. It's fairly new,
but I am going to go over some security
stuff near the end of the video. But you
could read through this to understand
what exactly this does. You basically
have one agent per character. You have
live activity tracking. You can design
the office with the floors, the
furniture, everything like that. You can
see speech bubbles. You get sound
notifications, sub agent visualization,
and there are six different characters
that could spawn. It'll go into some
requirements and it will go into some
things about how to actually use it. But
if you want to test it out, then hop in
here. And here is where unfortunately it
says that it's right now Windows only
testing. And on the road map, you can
see that there's lots of things they
want to add like having cloud code agent
teams because right now it's just like
parallel agents. So anyways, once you
have installed that, what you're going
to do is open up a folder. So, let's
just say you come to the explorer and
you open up a project that you want to
be working in. So, here I just opened up
my Herk 2, which is basically like my
second brain executive assistant type of
deal. It's really weird, but if you want
to get this project to work, your folder
cannot have a space or a period in it.
As you can see down here, this used to
be called Herkace 2.0 and then it was
Herk 2.0 and now it's herk-2. So, make
sure you don't have those things in
there if you want the pixel agents to
actually pick up the activity log and
actually reflect what you're doing.
You're welcome. I had to learn that the
hard way. So once you're in here, you're
going to open up the terminal. So if I'm
on Windows, I'm going to do control and
then the little tilda. And this opens up
the terminal. And then here is where you
can see I have a pixel agents tab, which
opens up the little workspace. Now what
I want to do is I want to see half and
half. So I basically grab this and drag
it to the sidebar, which lets me look at
it over here. And then all I have to do
is click on plus agent. And that
basically opens up a cloud code terminal
on the right hand side. And it spawns in
an agent right here. As you can see now,
right now, this agent is idle because
it's not working on anything. So, if I
go ahead and say, "Please spin up a
research agent and just find out what's
going on with small businesses and AI
adoption." And I go ahead and shoot that
off, then this agent should pick up that
task, and it should also spin up a sub
agent. I'm going to add another one that
opens up another terminal, and I can add
more and more agents. So, we can see
that we could watch all five of these
different terminals run at the same
time. And then what you can do in here
is you can go to your layout and you can
change things up. So I could move around
this plant for example. I can move that
right here. I could go to furniture and
I have storage. I have tech. I have
decor. I have all this kind of stuff. I
could literally just put a monitor in
the middle of the kitchen floor if I
wanted to. And I could keep adding more
and more. So it's kind of funny. You can
fully customize the way that this looks
and um the colors of like the floors and
the walls and things like that. And the
other setting that you can really play
around with would be opening the
sessions folder to see what's going on,
which opens up like a folder like this
to see activity log and stuff. You can
also go to the debug view to see what
the agents are actually working on. And
you can turn on or off the sound
notifications, which is pretty cool. You
could obviously use something like hooks
to do that either way, but it's nice
that that is now sort of native with
this extension. So, I'm not going to
spend too much time here really. I think
you guys all understand exactly what's
going on. You can see that this agent
just finished up. Great timing. I
thought I should wrap up this video by
actually just talking about like what is
the point of this? Is this just like
useless? So my first point is about
entertainment. I think that there is
value to having this as just like kind
of something that's fun. And the reason
I say that is kind of twofold. The first
one is I a lot of times like I said
earlier have two monitors up and I'll
have cloud code going over here and I'll
be working on other things here. And it
is kind of nice to be able to look over
and just see like how many agents are up
or you know do I need to load them up
more tasks. But the other piece of it is
I think that it's visual and that might
lure some people in who aren't super
technical or who are intimidated by
looking at a terminal. I think it's very
similar to how Nedn started to blow up
is because they visually had some good
elements that people felt like they
could actually understand just by
looking at. And that kind of leads into
my second point which is about that is
exactly what AI coding is lacking is
visual elements because kind of like I
said earlier what we're looking at is a
terminal or you know basically a chat
window when in n or something like that
you're seeing visual workflows you're
seeing the process of the data and
you're seeing things be built or you
know changed now obviously pixel agents
isn't that it's not a representation of
what's they're actually doing it's just
like showing you how many are working
but I definitely think it's a step in
the right direction cuz I think
ultimately Where I'd love to go is to a
place where cloud code builds me, you
know, workflows and automations and it's
showing me it building them in an NEN
style interface where I can see the flow
and then we can talk about multi- aent
monitoring. There's a lot that can go on
with different agents whether you run
them in parallel and different terminals
or you've got sub agents or you've got
agent teams. And it was kind of cool in
here that you know each of these people
are their own terminal. And so if I see
four of this girl, I know that that is
one main and then four sub agents.
Whereas all of these are just different
agents running in terminals because they
are different things. Parallel agents,
you know, four different terminal
agents. Sub agents are a parent
delegating tasks to different sub aents.
Those sub agents can use different
models and they have, you know, their
own independent context. And then you
have agent teams which pixel agent
doesn't yet actually show. But agent
teams work together a little bit better.
They don't share context necessarily,
but they share a task list. they can
talk to each other and they understand
when the other person is done or the
other agent is done. And even Boris, the
genius who is kind of like behind Cloud
Code said that he's using, you know,
five agents in his terminal at all times
and then maybe another 10 on the web or
something like that. So, he's always
working with tons of different agents.
So, I am really interested to see what
Cloud Code does around sort of like more
native visualization. So, real quick,
let's hit on the security of this plugin
because you should really only be
installing extensions that are verified
or that you know are safe. So before I
installed it, I just looked into it a
little bit. The publisher is named Pablo
Deuca. He is a verified publisher on the
VS Code marketplace. I looked into his
background and he is a real person. He
is a co-founder of a company and he has
a GitHub repo with 1300 stars and over
100 forks. So I think that that means
that he's got a little bit of
credibility to him. He didn't make some
sort of fake profile to put something up
there to steal your data. So we looked
at some key things like outbound network
calls, data xfiltration, shell command
injection, suspicious dependencies,
credentials, secret handling, file
system access, and remote script
loading. And we didn't see anything. So
it doesn't look like it sends data
anywhere. It doesn't collect anything.
It doesn't run any commands and
everything is staying on your machine.
So that is why I felt confident to
actually install this and test it out.
So I just wanted to share my experience
from a security perspective. So overall,
the way I feel about this is that pixel
agent just tells me that an agent or
agents are working. What I actually want
to know is what they're building, what
decisions they're making, and whether
it's about to do something that I'd
agree with or disagree with. That's the
real product that I think we need when
it comes to visualization. Because us as
humans, we're moving into this world
where we really just have to be really
good managers and keep our agents and
our sub agents on the right path. And
the best way to do that is be able to
just see all the time what's going on,
stop things before they go wrong, and
proactively keep giving them more work
so that they're never just sitting there
idle. But anyways, that is going to do
it for today. If you guys want to dive
deeper into all this kind of stuff and
nerd out, then definitely check out my
paid group, AI Automation Society Plus.
We've got over 3,000 members who are
building with AI every day and building
businesses with AI. So, it's a great
place to be if you have similar goals.
But if you guys enjoyed the video or you
learned something new, please give it a
like. It definitely helps me out a ton.
And as always, I appreciate you guys
making it to the end of the video. I'll
see you on the next one. Thanks,
everyone.